la magie des fêtes de noël terminé les
sapins se retrouvent généralement sur le
trottoir pour les récupérer les employés
de la société plaisir ouah c'est pur
spécialisée dans le traitement des
déchets sont mobilisés ce mardi 10
janvier les agents sillonné les rues
d'el en cours pour réaliser au mieux sa
tâche alexander dominguez qui travaille
depuis cinq ans sur 50 en yvelines à
cette technique est ferme pour détention
parce que normalement que les sapins pas
normal qu il était déclarée volée un
bout du chemin il fait plus attention
mais les saints par quatre fois pendant
ce mois de janvier ils encourent les
agents vont devoir batailler avec les
épines pour retirer les conifères de la
voie publique
on connaît notre match et donc pas y'a
pas de base et voilà ça a rien changé
donc tout va bien à montigny le
bretonneux les sapins sont collectées
depuis le 2 janvier par la vie dans
dix-neuf enclos de dépôt une fois
récupérés par les agents municipaux les
conifères sont broyés dans les services
techniques de la commune l'initiative a
été lancée depuis 2013 je crois en fait
on les broie sur place ici on a une
benne qui régulièrement par notre
société de qui elle marcher sur la
déchetterie nous emmène donc c'est
déchets verts sur l'autre la ville de
plaisir grignon il ya une déchetterie
une grande déchetterie sur place là bas
et ensuite par la suite on peut
récupérer mais après on mélange et une
fois composter ce type de matériau
environ 2500 sapins seront brouillés à
montigny le bretonneux pour récupérer
entre 30 et 40 mètres cubes de compost
l'opération s'achèvera le lundi 23
janvier